we got um after basketball practice one  day one of the teammates  yeah that's great sixth grade sixth  grade actually pulled a gun on me and  Keith yeah basketball and said give me  all your money I said man you robbing  the poorest black kid  this is a white kid or a black kid it's  a black kid  yeah they tried to Rob two broke ass  Brothers two black guys  I think I gave him a quarter  and I think I had a couple of shiny red  pennies that's all he got yeah wow and  that was on the black side of town and  this kid was our age what was we 12 13.  he's already got it I think it was 10  11. yeah and he put it right to our face  and Robin's but the coach saw him yeah  and they caught us in the school the  next day said what happened I said yeah  Michael pulled a gun on me and then he  and they said and then they expelled  them